reason is the certainty of consciousness
that it is all reality thus does
idealism express its notion just as
consciousness that comes on the scene as
reason possesses that certainty directly
in itself so too does idealism give
direct expression to that certainty I am
I in the sense that the I which is an
object for me is the sole object is all
reality and all that is present here the
I that is object for me is not merely an
empty object in general as it is for
self consciousness and such nor is it as
in free self consciousness merely an
object that withdraws itself from other
objects which retain their worth
alongside it on the contrary it is for
self consciousness an object such that
any other object whatever is a non being
but self consciousness is all reality
not merely for itself but also in itself
only through becoming this reality or
rather through demonstrating itself to
be such it demonstrates itself to be
this along the path in which first in
the dialectical movement of meaning
perceiving and understanding other
necessity' intrinsic being vanishes then
in the movement through the independence
of consciousness and lordship and
bondage through the conception of
freedom through the liberation that
comes from skepticism and the struggle
for absolute liberation by the
consciousness divided against itself
other nests insofar as it is only for
consciousness vanishes for consciousness
itself there appeared two aspects one
after the other one in which the essence
or the true had for consciousness the
determinate nosov being the other in
which it had the determinants of being
only for consciousness but the to
reduced themselves to a single truth
that is what that that what is or the in
itself only is insofar as it is for
consciousness and what is for
consciousness is also in itself
or has intrinsic being the consciousness
which is this truth has this path behind
it him as he has forgotten it and comes
on the scene immediately as reason in
other words this reason which comes
immediately on the scene appears only as
the certainty of that truth thus it
merely asserts that it is all reality
but does not itself comprehend this for
it is a long that forgotten path that
this immediately expressed assertion is
comprehended and equally anyone who has
not trod on this path finds this
assertion incomprehensible when he hears
it in this pure form although he does as
a matter of fact make the assertion
himself in a concrete shape that is the
assertion is implicit in his behavior
Cagle is beginning this section reason
with some pretty major claims he's
already done quite a bit of that and now
he's going to provide us a bit more
context for the claims that are being
made he's actually helping us to see
that in a certain sense idealism the way
that it's been framed in what we're
going to talk about his reason as
immediately coming out of the scene
seems rather difficult to accept the
idealist is making some pretty major
declarations in saying that that reason
or consciousness is all reality so we
want to see how that pans up what's
actually going on with that and what's
going to be particularly important is
this forgot we have that we have just
traced through all of these previous
paragraphs that we've done all this
discussion and commentary
remember too that it's very important
for pengelley and philosophy then well
we do leave previous states of
consciousness consciousness behind in
the sense that there's no more
development going on with them we don't
totally leave them behind as in the you
know the old metaphor of throwing away
the ladder once we've climbed up rather
you can think of it as bringing all the
essential stuff along so let's start
wearing Hegel starts here with you know
I'm talking about the notion of idealism
what is what is the notion or the
concept of idealism idealism is a
philosophical standpoint but also as
he's going to say a little bit later at
the end of this section a practical
standpoint as well well it's to say that
reason and as consciousness is in fact
all reality that it becomes certain of
itself as being all reality so what does
that mean that that's why when you make
claims like that people are reluctant to
accept them and said well you think that
you your consciousness
is actually all over reality that's not
quite what Hegel is is saying here even
though the language does seem to suggest
that so let's look at what he's got here
he says just as consciousness that comes
on the scene as reason possesses that
certainty directly in itself so too does
idealism give direct expression to that
certainty what is that certainty it's
expressed in this i am i if you go as
the hyundai says it's i am i in the
sense that the i which is an object for
me is the sole object is all reality and
all that is present so does that mean
that i as in Gregory Sadler is the only
thing that is reality that you are
somehow say a figment of my imagination
or you know everything around me falls
into that no that's that's not what he's
saying all right there the pure eye as
we're going to see developed in these
later paragraphs has to be sort of drawn
out right now a pure eye is sort of an
empty signifier you might say so he says
the eyes of this object for me is not
merely an empty object in general as it
is for self consciousness as such right
self consciousness at the beginning
doesn't have that much to work with
it needs content we still need content
here so what is it that says nor is it
as in free self consciousness merely an
object that withdraws itself from other
objects which retain their worth along
science so when he's talking about free
self consciousness he's talking about
the development that took place in the
you know lordship and bondage or
master-slave dialectic after the the
struggles of the death and he's talking
about the developments that we just go
on through in terms of stoicism
skepticism and the unhappy
consciousness trying the consciousness
trying to make sense of the fact that it
is indeed free and also at the same time
does not yet possess its truth or when
it does possess its truth that loses its
certainty as Hegel will tell us
so in these previous stages before we
get to to here right then the path that
we've been tracing out the when we said
I am I which we said back in these
earlier sections it's sort of effaced
things right and we saw there were
problems with that same thing here the I
I am I is sort of empty but at the same
time it's another being that can also
say I am I that as opposed to it and we
we saw that play itself probably the
unhappy consciousness in particular
there's an estrangement that goes on
within consciousness so he says it's not
these on the contrary it is for self
consciousness an object such that any
other object whatever is a non being so
the eye is an object for itself in
saying I am I I'm not just acting as
subject
I'm also acting as object but the eye
there is you might say extending into
the entire universe not just the
universe of perception by the way - or
you know Sensibility well literally
everything so he goes on and he says
self-consciousness is all reality not
merely for itself but also in itself
only through becoming this reality or
through demonstrating itself to be such
so this is a really key point it is one
thing for self consciousness to assert
in a you might say naive or you know
aggressive against the world kind of
stance everything belongs to me it would
also be similar
- you know a sort of a narcissistic
circling around you know a nurse
assistant would not be the same thing as
what Hegel is talking about here in
reason because the narcissist is never
going to make any progress if they do
they quit being a narcissist or hey or
at least become less of one instead
what's happening is there has to be a
development that takes place he talks in
terms here of a demonstration that means
it's working out for itself what is
actually going on what it itself is and
what it's doing so he says it
demonstrates itself to be this along a
path look at the peril that it traced
out in the previous stages of the
dialectic he says in which first in the
dialectical movement of meaning okay so
we have meaning
perceiving understanding and in those
frames in those those dialectics and
those you know developments that took
place building off of each other
awareness is treated as intrinsic being
and over and over again what we think to
be intrinsic being doesn't really have
intrinsic meaning whether it's the the
object that we we gesture towards or
trying to name the thing that we think
has immediacy in terms of some sense
certainty whether it's the thing that we
perceive the thing with its qualities
right
none of that turns out to be a purely
stable ground that we can rest them or
even the understanding itself understood
those well thing there is circularity
understood as a faculty a faculty that
is able to grasp something that goes
beyond mere perception or Sensibility
it's able to grasp you might say the
metaphysical ground well that
metaphysical ground turns out to be a
shifting one in these lots so other Ness
keeps on vanishing and and some people
have expressed some frustration as they
go through those
understandably so because it seems like
everything turns into a banishing point
what is Hegel actually holding on to
well we do hold on to some of this the
you might say there's a residue on what
we've passed through so that's the first
stage that's consciousness right that's
an intersection now we have
self-consciousness and Hegel goes on in
this this passage and he says here we go
it demonstrates itself to be this along
the path right then in the movement
through the independence of
consciousness in lordship and bondage
through the conception of freedom
through the liberation that comes from
skepticism and it's struggle for
absolute liberation by the consciousness
divided against itself when is others
elderness become something for
consciousness but it vanishes for
consciousness itself by the time that we
we get finished with it right so there's
this constant play of trying to you know
the self and the other trying to grasp
what the other actually does and all of
this was a very important set of
developments so he says there appeared
two aspects one after the other one in
which the essence or the true he had for
consciousness the determinate missus
being the other in which again the
determinists of being only for
consciousness so you know determinate
nosov being that is the in itself and
being for consciousness that is the for
consciousness or the in the case of
consciousness for itself right
and now Hegel is going to bring these
two together in what he calls a single
truth a truth that has two sides to it
but where the two sides are supposed to
be melded together you know reflecting
different aspects of the same thing the
in itself is for consciousness when we
say and we've seen this this said before
right we already saw this back in in
this section the consciousness section
waiting trying to postulate something
out there that would be in it
self and totally opaque to or resistant
to consciousness
how are you conceptualizing them how are
you even talking about that
how are you have imagining it you're
doing that in your consciousness right
the mere fact that I can talk about this
with you means that you are also
thinking about it and I'm thinking about
it in the angles thinking about it so
the in itself is in itself in itself but
also for consciousness that's one side
what it is for consciousness is also in
itself a lot of times people want to you
know this is a little bit of a
digression here but it's kind of
important when we talked about idealism
idealism has come to mean something
quite different in in modern parlance
than it did in you know you know earlier
times when Hegel was was using and
taking the term you know from others
before him white-hot for example and a
lot of people associated with a kind of
you know fuzzy-headed you're living in
the realm of ideas you're not practical
you're not grounded in things that
really are you know like like books or
or neckties or chalkboards things you
can touch things that you that you could
say that's about right he and what we
forget in that this is really one of the
great insights of the Hegelian
philosophy is that ideas are also
realities ideas you have to be drawn out
the notion you know when it first comes
on the scene is not fully developed but
ideas have a kind of power you can
unfold them into reality and it's not
just an annotation of our thought onto
reality our thinking is a real thing our
thinking is itself part of reality it's
not something totally opposed to it or
you know it's custard a hazy picture of
it the for consciousness has some in
itself to it and so Hegel is insisting
that we recognize this so he says the
consciousness which is this truth with
which the consciousness that grasped the
single truth has this path behind it
here's the problem it's forgotten that
path you know you could just turn to the
edge of the bar right and once you
actually start doing the sorts of things
that that reason corresponds to both
conceptually and historically you you
might well forget about all this stuff
and leave it behind and say I have this
is the real stuff that I'm interested in
I'm just going to focus on this the
problem with that is that when reason
comes on the scene immediately as such
he says reason which comes immediately
on the scene appears only as a certainty
of that truth it merely asserts that it
is all reality it's one thing to assert
it and it's none of things to be able to
adequately explain it or demonstrate it
or to to make sense of it to oneself and
so Hegel is is conceding that when
idealism comes on the scene where reason
comes on the scene and forgets about all
this stuff behind it it's same stuff
that sounds kind of crazy yeah that's
okay because that is itself part of the
historical development here he says you
know it's it's a long they've forgotten
path that this immediately expressed
assertion is comprehended you want to
understand you say you understand this
this this this assertion here then you
need to keep this other stuff in mind
now what he says will to end this is
very interesting he says anyone who does
not trot in this path finds this
assertion incomprehensible when he hears
it in its pure form although he does as
a matter of fact make the assertion
himself in a concrete shape Miller has
here is a gloss on that the the
assertion is implicit in his behavior
and that is worth keeping in mind I'm
not going to say much about that right
now but keep that in mind when we get to
later portions of Reason where we're
looking at for example the dial
between you know pleasure and necessity
where we're talking about practical
affairs where we're talking about
practical reason in action
the idealism that does not demonstrate
that path but starts off with this
assertion is therefore - a pure
assertion which does not comprehend its
own self nor can it make itself
comprehensible to others it proclaims an
immediate certainty which is confronted
by other immediate certainties which
have however been lost on that same path
with equal right therefore the
assertions of these other certainties to
take their place alongside the assertion
of that certainty reason appeals to the
self-consciousness of each and every
consciousness I am I my object in my
essence is I and no one will deny reason
this truth but in basing itself on this
appeal reason sanctions the truth of the
other certainty that is that there is
for me and other that an other than I is
object and essence for me or in that I
am object in essence to myself I am only
so by drawing back from the other
altogether and taking my place as an
actuality alongside it not until reason
comes on the scene as a reflection from
this opposite certainty does its
affirmation about itself present itself
not merely as a certainty and an
assertion but as truth and that merely
alongside other truths but as the sole
truth it's immediate appearance on the
scene is the abstraction of its actual
presence the essence and the in itself
of which is the absolute notion that is
the movement which is which is brought
into it into being consciousness will
determine its relationship to other
Nisour its object in various ways
according to the precise stage it is
reached in the development of the world
spirit into self consciousness how it
immediately finds and determines itself
and its object at any time or the way in
which it is for itself depends on what
it has already become or what it already
is in itself
now in paragraph 234 we're going to see
Hegel bringing back in this dynamic
relationship between the self and the
other in a very explicit way one that's
that's quite important for understanding
how does that reason works and you know
I said it just a few paragraphs back in
the last paragraph that some of what
he's saying you know if you take that
the wrong way sounds pretty crazy I am
all reality that sounds rather strange
to say but that is something that the
idealist is is maintaining the question
is and this is a very important question
for any sort of idealism how do you take
account of there being multiple you
could say centers of agency of
development of consciousness right and
this is what he's touching out here he's
not providing me with a complete
solution here but he is framing the
problem in a very explicit way so he
says the idealism that doesn't
demonstrate the path that starts off
with this assertion is therefore to a
pure assertion which doesn't comprehend
its own self consciousness does not
really understand itself it is making
the assertion I am everything because
it's forgotten its previous path that we
just talked about in the last paragraph
says it also can't make itself
comprehensible to others and it's not
just the self that's in this boat it's
any other that's also doing this at the
same time so he says it proclaims an
immediate certainty which is confronted
by other immediate certainties so in
proclaiming it's its own immediate
certainty it has to take a of the fact
that there are other immediate
certainties and I have only got one on
the board but we can think of an entire
world of other immediate certainties we
could go back and forth from this is
where idealism starts to seem a little
less crazy
right because it's not saying I am the
only conscious being in the world as a
matter of fact there's all these other
conscious beings and now the question is
how am I connected with them and how are
they connected with me so if we're all
doing this immediate certainty right
just sort of imagining this he says on
each of these have been lost on the same
path with equal right the assertion of
these other certainties take their place
alongside the assertion of that
certainty so these are both kind of on
and equal right and you know this
immediate certainty is saying that some
I am I missing mean if certainty over
there can also say to itself I am I and
meaning by that I am all reality I am
all reality and they're not saying we're
both a horizontality together there's a
it's not competing at this point that
there's a tension there and how do I see
the other well that I is there's also I
now is that I I in the sense of being me
or is that I in the sense of being him
or her you know this is where things
start to get stinky don't they and we
see the importance of this this function
of the eye like it's talked about quite
a bit by later thinkers you know ranging
from star to Lacan you know we can do a
lot of plays on words with this but I
ins kind of a function that's a key idea
so he goes on and he says reason appeals
to the self-consciousness of each and
every consciousness I am I my object of
my essence is I so the question is okay
where is the object in the essence is it
RI the object in essence for myself but
not for anybody else or is this other
eye over here also an object and essence
for me something of concern something
within the purview of my reason it's
hard
extricate myself totally from them right
so nobody says no one will deny the
reason this truth in basing itself on
this is the reason sanctions the truth
of the other certainty that there is for
me and other that an other than I is an
object in essence for me so this is a
very important isn't it I am object in
essence for myself in saying I am i but
if I'm going to do that for myself I
have to also concede it over here for
this other being which turns out to also
be my object and essence but that means
that my object in essence aren't totally
in myself or in my consciousness and you
know we saw how this can you know lead
to all sorts of interesting dynamics
back in the self consciousness section
right and things to work through so
that's coming up again here but in terms
of reason so he says this is the this is
what the other certainty is right this
other certainty is not just the other
certainty over here it's a certainty
about that other certainty and he says
there we go
I am only so by drawing back from the
other altogether and taking my place as
an actuality a lot science right so
there's a sort of removal
it says not until reason comes on the
scene as a reflection from this opposite
certainty does its affirmation about
itself present itself not merely as a
certainty and as an assertion but as
truth so what we're trying to get at
here is again not just having certainty
but the truth of reason and that is
going to require some sort of process of
reflection that is taking the other
certainty as object in essence as as the
other into consideration and something
that is part of my consciousness now
that's that's kind of a tall order isn't
it but we're going to see this worked
out so he says if the immediate
appearance on the scene is the
abstraction of its
actual presents the immediate appearance
of what of reason on the scene the
essence in the in itself of which is the
absolute notion that is the movement
which is brought it into being what does
that movement that movement is this yeah
so says consciousness will determine its
relation to other nests where its object
in various ways depending on what
depending is your Hegel says on its the
state according to the precise stage is
reached in the development of world
spirit into self consciousness
so which stage in the dialectic we have
managed to reach is going to determine
how we relate ourselves to the the
others or like the object which is also
our self or a self all of this depends
on how far along we've gotten and
whether or not we've left so much behind
that we don't realize where we've come
very interesting insight here isn't it
so he says how it immediately finds it
determines itself or and its object at
any time
or the way in which it is it is for
itself depends on what it has already
become or what it already is in itself
the for in itself is how it understands
itself right but also how it understands
itself in relation to its object and
then based on where it has been you know
what if he has become as Hegel is saying
so there's a certain element what you
could call what's called an you know to
use sart's term facticity or you know
certain historical more it if you like
and you can't really get away from that
you can't jumpstart beyond previously
stages the dialectic that are not
previous for you but you know which
would be previous for for somebody
else's further state you actually have
to
ress through them and if eagle is right
as he said in the preface that we even
actually forgotten much of the previous
stages we also need to sort of bring
that back into the picture in order for
us to understand where we currently are
in relation to ourselves and in relation
to the other